welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's webinar a complete sample
to insight solution for detection and
classification of challenging pathogenic
Birka mutations it is presented by Anika
yoker PhD the Associate Director of
Global Product Management for
next-generation sequencing at cryogen
and jennifer Poitras PhD the principle
genome scientist in bioinformatics for
genetic disease at kya gen my name is
Julie O'Rourke and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented my lab routes and
sponsored by kaya gen for more
information about our sponsor visit
wkyt.com before we begin I would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box our speakers will
respond to your questions via email
following the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
experiencing a problem this presentation
is educational and they'll software's
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now without further ado please
join me in welcoming dr. yogurt and dr.
Poitras I will now turn the presentation
over to them
thank you very much father in
bactrim my name is anneka Yuka and I
will tell you a little bit about the
challenges of the detection of
challenging accommodations in the end of
this happiness on second telephones the
recognizer gives them all to my
colleague Jennifer partners who will
tell you a little bit more about the
classification in the interpretation of
those challenging pathogenic poker
mutations and also a case story
so what are the challenges if you want
to detect learn variance in Parker one
and pocket or by using NGS technology
the first one is a cube ones no gaps in
both of the genes so you won't 100% with
coverage of all of the exons and maybe
also the interim and exon boundaries
because you want to detect variants
which are playable for example in
splicing
the second point goes to it if you don't
have one of percent wheat coverage
you're not able to detect all the
pathogenic or actionable variants so of
course you want one a percent
sensitivity and at the same time very
low false positive weight
the equity classification and
interpretation is also very challenging
because of the US for example identify
the snip in one of the vodka one of
vodka two genes you don't know is that
is pathogenic or benign and therefore an
accurate classification and
interpretation is of especially interest
here
so when we are looking at those
challenging variants there's a lot of
bottlenecks when you try to detect them
so the first one is for example that you
want to detect variance in homo polymer
regions many people are not aware of
that but waka 1m Parker to have variance
in small homo polymer regions and on
this slide you can see a stretch of
eighth and some there in this case as a
small deletion X in this case actually
not delusional inversion of one of the
bases which is often overseen by many
other programs but also by whole systems
that goes to the next point so most of
the pathogenic variants in waka waka to
Allah small or large deletions and
insertions of all kinds of sizes all
started with one base pair and it ends
up by the half the whole gene deleted so
in this case and you want to make sure
to detect all of those and that goes to
the next point so if you want to detect
all kinds of sizes of deletions and
insertions then you'll also look at copy
number variants in this case for example
that bracha one for example is deleted
or amplified but let's think about for
example if one exon is just deleted in
this case it will be pretty hard to
detect cells if you have a panel with
just been the exon regions and you don't
have the breakpoints covered which are
lying and ventral but copy number
variant detection helps in that regard
and can detect excellent level copy
numbers like exon with an exon deleted
or amplified so the first point and goes
after you have identify those variants
you want to interpret those first you
want to classify them which are the ones
are benign which are one or are
pathogenic and you want not many of
unknown significance because they need
follow-up actions and at the end after
you've done the classification and also
for the classification you want to have
a sender that system so you always want
to do it in the same way to also compare
to each other and always gives the same
recommendation you want to have a really
good reporting order source so
standardization is very important for
that part
some time ago we asked our customers and
also other people are working in ng as
what are your pains and what I said to
us we have we have a fragmented workflow
and we don't know how to optimize it and
they also pointed out that I have
problems with bioinformatics so with
analyzing the Swedes and to detect the
variance and with the interpretation of
data the analysis of the data is often
connected to the fragmented workflow so
because if you have a five-minute
workflow let's say for example your
sample extraction comes from kyochon
your library preparation or your panel
for example comes from a completely
different vendor then you have the
sequencing machine from someone else
in the bioinformatics from the search
and vendor and something goes wrong was
not really optimized you can there for
example the best paramedics on earth but
you will get bad results if the other
parts of the workflow are not working
well together so the whole system needs
to be optimized and we also people also
told us they have no clue what the cost
of Sanjay as tests are so often for
example maintenance costs are overseen
so someone hires for example a bantam
attrition is an app and then that this
person cost money is overseen for a very
long time so it was a very high
affectionate couldn't tell us what
they're paying per sample but they said
in general the cost for NGOs are very
high and too high
and really lacks is testimonial from one
of our customers
so he said already in 2017
that people tend to largely
underestimate the true cost of running
and NGS system because they are not
considering the cost offer of the
lengthy and pricey optimization process
for all of the components
so he was also one of the first
customers college in winter NGS system
which I would like to introduce to you
so gene with NGS system is not just a
sequencer so what you get is a complete
solution which includes the sample
extraction and it ends into the data
interpretation and all of these parts
are optimized so when we play the system
into your neck
it comes with automation so you get for
example automation for example a kayak
cube or you can run it on your car
Symphony also part of library
preparation is automated you get a gene
wakaya cube for the cool amplification
and gene reader for the sequencing and
QC analyze for the eternal livers and
what you also get is QC enter put for
the data interpretation
so as quality control we are relying on
two different parts so one is a cubed
system to check the quality of the DNA
extraction that also the magic
preparation and the kind excess system
for fragment length and in
identification
for support there are several ways also
the good news is whatever goes wrong
into the system you can always blame us
and we are ready to help you so we are
ready was also paused and you will get
hands books not always on paper but also
we have a little episode you get an iPad
which guides you to all the steps for
the different effects you have on the
system from sample to inside
and what it also makes it unique if
you're running many samples you want to
exactly know which sample is at work
step in the workflow so here we have our
gene with linked system which you can
connect to your lymph system and when
you can know where you know it's like an
electronic lab book and you know exactly
weight sample is at which point of the
workshop
so as I said all the we call it panels
what you want on the system each of the
panels are actually small sample to
inside solutions which come with their
old handbook and because of that yeah we
we promise you so that we get when you
get the system into your net and you get
fully trained and after installation in
30 days you can use it in a routine way
as I said the system was not just a
sequencing box and the things are
getting pre optimized from the simple
extraction into the reporting so they're
far dead in the system comes with very
specific assays which can be run on the
system so most of them are actually all
of them are ecology focused
except one with our custom channel where
we have also a good way for example to
have all kinds of hereditary diseases
would be in covered as well so you can
decide what is on the panel which
regions are targeted and it works
exactly like the other ones
so before we are putting any of those
panels on the market we are not only
developing them but we are also
optimizing them with the front part so
with a simple extraction and the lab
preparation into the sequencer and
including the bioinformatics up to the
data interpretation so currently we have
both - bracha panels available -
actionable insights to more parents of
different sizes one specific for Laing
focusing on DNA infusions and the new
one for myeloid leukemia
so for today I would like to focus on
the one for Paco
so one of those and that's our newest
addition the black advance panel uses
unique molecular index technology so the
other one is both of them IP components
but the new world market runs and uses a
unique molecular index technology which
is very fantastic - on the first side
find out what is true and what is wrong
so for example false positives is it can
easily be so that out because each of
the sequencing weeks each of the
biomarkers gets labeled before the
amplification and then after after get
amplified sweet are sharing same
molecular index then you know they're
coming from the same biomolecule and if
you see for example like this yeah green
one where only one variant was just and
one week and the other weeds coming from
the same biomolecule it does not share
the same variant then you know this is
was positive a two variant would appear
in all of those weeds therefore you can
easily get the width of amplification
errors and this is also very important
if we think about copy number variation
detection they're found in new panel of
the new si can detect also copy number
variation detection down to the X or
never
so we tested
hello before it came to the market on
different data sets one is reference
samples and the other one is clinical
samples and here you see this was from a
reference sample for somatic with
somatic block invitations and what is
very interesting in this reference
sample is editors three variants in
normal polymer regions which I said
before it was really hard to detect and
often missed by many pipelines because
these regions tend to many rows so you
can see here this leads to deletions and
one inversions all of them are just one
base pair low and if the third one is
very interesting because it's them at an
allelic frequency of just 7% so we just
yeah more rare and that's more often
also bit like the backward level where
you would not detect it so we optimize
the system to really detect also those
variants and we could show that in all
samples that we detected them at a not
present since a sentence I can also
detect copy number variation and they
cannot only do that to say that Wacka
Wacka Wacka 2 is deleted or amplified
but also down to the exon never so how
is it able to do that so when you want
to find out something is heated or
amplified and from the biometric
standpoint you use copy number variation
detection then the copy number variation
with textual algorithm needs to learn
how normal looks like so you can see
that here we see two so in the middle um
this we call baseline this is normal so
normal um is not one specific specials
but I'm really arranged and that is
because you can have good or bad
coverages between different sequencing
ones so you have inter one variability
you have also changed in coverage
between the samples so you have good and
bad DNA
and you can have variability in part of
the components of the workflow for
example if you change your extraction
kit or you change your library
preparation kit it will change the
baseline
so the a grocer needs to learn how does
learner look like and this is pretty
challenging so what does Jean with a
system with Ibaka advance the panel did
was our tag result in three different
parts the first one is that it uses
unique molecular indexes including an
optimized bioinformatics pipeline to
remove the amplification bias this is
very important because the copy number
variation detection algorithm uses to
reach coverage and tries to compare if
it's higher or lower than normal the
second part of that on the panel are
housekeeping genes so it turns to see on
1 1 M if it's higher or lower than the
genes on the panel and the third one and
that is what requires really a sample to
insert system if it learns or it has
learned before how the in B baseline
looks like so there are many samples
ones whose a complete system
so this Envy based on creation takes a
lot of time and resources and is often
underestimated for many people so you
have to run many sample through the
system and if you do it alone with
algorithms you don't know you will need
to understand really well as the
algorithm does and not all the
algorithms allows you actually to learn
so therefore what we are doing we are
establishing the CNB based on beforehand
and because we are owning the whole
system we can actually do it so if we do
see and be calling here or at your lab
it will exactly it will have the same
result because we are not changing
anything of the complete workflow
a second example is Baraka germline
mutation detection
for that snapshot lots of complete
verification data but in this case for
the first part we use 12 semper 11 blood
samples from in one reference helpers so
it was partly what was clinical samples
and then one little sample so we wanted
to the complete workflow you can see
here approximately the steps so samples
they extracted then their barcode labels
the regions were amplified so dependence
does not only cover on the exon regions
of Paco but also 20 base pair into Z
into an egregious of each of the site so
then the libraries were generated and
one has to have flex on the G meter
system and automatically then after
water data were analyzed with QC I
analyzed and then from there they were
uploaded to QC interpret so there's a
button you can click from the software
and then automatically classify it by
using the ACMG guidelines so we were
able in all of these cases where we know
the variance to detect event event into
the certain was only out of this case
achieved 100 percent sensitivity we also
didn't detect any false positives a
specific interest here was
was one variant you can see this year
which was actually in the intronic
region so it was some base pairs into Z
intronic regions and it was classified
as pathogenic so if you for example have
a panel which just covers the exonic
regions you would have missed own
variant we also looked at the literature
supporting this event because we're
starting grants you are never sure and
there are three cases in the pending
case two cases which supports this
variant in the literature as pathogenic
so is that some I like to give the ball
to my chronic Jennifer who will give you
more insight into the interpretation and
the reporting of those yeah challenging
variants and also other variants in
Parker thank you
Thank You Annika so as Annika just
mentioned I'll be speaking about QC I
interpret so this is the final step in
the solution so we talked about
identifying variants using the gene
reader system and can see I analyzed so
now what QC I interpret will do is it
will tell you you know which of the
variants that you've identified are
actually clinically relevant so in the
case of somatic alterations on the right
we automatically compute actionability
using the amp tearing system and for
germline variants which you can see on
the left we use the ACMG scoring
framework and I'll explain throughout
the talk exactly how this works and
while I'll really be focusing on
classifying germline variants especially
in the context of baraka I do want to
emphasize that QC I interpret can
classify actionability of somatic
variants and alterations as well as a
pathogenicity of germline variants
so for those of you who might not be
aware on several years ago the American
College of medical genetics created this
evidence-based framework to standardize
variant interpretation and you can see
that there are several rules or criteria
that are organized into these
evidence-based categories including
functional data for example and
segregation data and these rules exist
along a continuum from benign to
pathogenic so what the variant
scientists must do is ask which of these
rules are criteria does my very satisfy
and then those rules in aggregate will
define whether or not a variant is
benign or pathogenic depending on the
combination of rules that are applied
and you can read more about this in the
publication cited below
so as I mentioned one must go to to
basically define which of these rules
variant satisfies the variant scientists
must go to many different resources to
evaluate this so first they'll look at
pubmed and see if there are variant
specific publications that are relevant
to the phenotype
additionally they'll look in public and
proprietary databases to see has my
variant been seen before and if so has
it been seen in the phenotype that I'm
interested in they'll also look in in
silico algorithms as well as population
frequency databases and this presents a
couple of different challenges first is
efficiency as this manual curation
process is very time consuming more
Boreas and the second is accuracy as you
can imagine that one might miss
something by looking at all these
different resources so what kyon is
really done is simplified this process
by centralizing all this information
into one resource known as the kaijin
knowledgebase so for the past 20 years
we've had MD and PhD level scientists
manually curating the literature and
putting in findings in a very controlled
and meticulous way on top of that we're
bringing in third-party information
including ole mem and clinical
trials.gov
to build this ontology such that we have
a rich resource of variants to phenotype
relationship so we can easily identify a
causal variant in the case of disease
and also classify those variants
so just this is an older slide but just
to give you proportionally an idea of
the breadth of coverage so on the left
you can see that the kaiju knowledge
base contains hgmd as well as clinvar
but on top of that because we're
curating from the literature the chi and
knowledge base adds 121 percent more
genes on top of that and now on the
right when we look at the variant level
the Chi G knowledge base because we're
curating from the literature as 159
percent more variants in addition to
what's in hgmd and clinvar so you can
see the tremendous value added by
curating from the literature and just to
give you an idea of spoken a lot about
findings but just to give you an idea of
how these findings are presented so this
is a publication that we actually
curated and there are three findings
associated with it and you can see we
list that at the top mutant EP 300 gene
increases the risk and then give you the
contextual information of the disease
and then in some cases also ethnicity
information
so if you've just seen how findings
appear from the information that we
curate and it is these findings that are
tied to the relevant rules within this
scoring framework so for this reason we
are uniquely able to automatically
compute variant classifications using
all 28a CMG rules so that significantly
speeds up the classification workflow
but how accurate is our automated
variant scoring so to evaluate this we
took expert panel assess baraka one and
two variants from clinvar and put those
through to CI to compare the Enigma
assessments with classifications and qci
so i should mention that enigma is the
expert panel that is extremely dedicated
to determining the clinical significance
of baraka one and two variants as well
as other known or suspected hereditary
breast cancer predisposition genes so
you can see up top what we've done is
looked for bracha one and two variants
that were expert panel assess and put
them through to CI and in this
particular example this variant is
concordant as it was pathogenic as we
assessed by the expert panel and also
was pathogenic as determined by our
automatically computed variant
classification in QC i
so what we found this amounted to over
six thousand brothel one and two
variants and what we found was extremely
impressive so in this graph you can see
at the very left eighty one point seven
percent of those six thousand cost
variants had the exact same
classification and qci as the expert
panel and then when we take into account
differences that should not affect
medical management so just to the right
you can see likely benign versus benign
for example when we add those together
we arrive at ninety nine point six
percent concordance with respect to
clinical actionability which is very
impressive then when we see on the right
there are these point four three percent
of differences that might affect medical
management so when I started digging
into those differences I realized that
the sources that discrepancy came from a
couple of different places one the
enigma specific variant scoring criteria
so they use some criterias it's outside
the ACMG framework so we can't really
control for that
additionally they don't consider
functional studies and we'll see how
both of those are impacted in the coming
slide so first let's take a look at the
concordant variant so for this
particular variant it was classified as
pathogenic by the end of macro panel and
also pathogenic and qci and you can see
how this information is displayed so in
the dashboard up top you can see the
gene is barakatu the transcript as well
as the HGVs nomenclature and that the
phenotype is hereditary breast and or
ovarian cancer and beneath we
transparently provide you with which of
those rules which I showed you in the
scoring framework in a previous slide
which of these rules were actually
triggered based on information that we
have in the knowledge base and to the
right of each of those rules there's an
evidence column so if there's evidence
supporting that from the literature
supporting each of those rules we
actually provide you with what evidence
was used to trigger those rules
so you can see here that ps4 was
actually triggered so this is a rule
that's asking is this variant
statistically enriched in cases versus
controls so since we have all these
cases and controls curated from the
literature and population databases we
are able to trigger this rule and there
are 24 pieces of literature that are
actually supporting this so those cases
so we're curating that triggered this
rule are coming from 24 publications and
I can actually access those 24
publications by clicking on the 24 and
display below you can see that these are
all the 24 publications as well as
relevant information is an individual or
a family study and other pieces of
information are provided and you can
directly link out to the abstract to any
of those publications here so you see I
interpret is not a black box we actually
provide you with the evidence used to
classify these variants
so now let's for a second look at a
discordant variance so in this
particular example this variance is
broccoli one variant we classified as
likely benign by enigma and you can see
that the evidence that they use to
support this classification was based on
a probabilistic model of placing
so when we actually put this variant
into qci you can see that we classify it
is likely pathogenic and this is based
on functional studies as I mentioned
enigma actually doesn't consider
functional studies and their
classification of variants so we
actually provide you with all the
information so that you can make that
judgment call so we had two functional
studies that actually supported
deleterious effect of this variant and
you can actually access what those two
functional studies are by selecting that
little number two and now you can see
that we have two publications that
actually I'm using a mini gene assay so
that introduction of this variant led to
exon skipping so we actually do have
some evidence to support that this
particular variant leads to a splicing
defect so you can see the power of
actually having all this evidence
curated and providing what that leads to
so in summary on the bracha panels on
the gene reader system utilized unique
molecular indices as Annika mentioned to
differentiate true variance from
amplification artifacts all panels on
the gene reader system are pre optimized
for sample extraction into the variant
detection and interpretation of variants
allowing the system to detect
challenging variants like CNVs down to
the exon level and also large deletions
and variants in Houma polymer difficult
regions sequencing files are
automatically from their analyzed qci
analyzed to accurately detect variants
in a very easy-to-use graphical user
interface those detected variants are
then taken to qci interpret which I just
spoke about to classify germline and
also somatic variants using the most
up-to-date knowledge and finally and the
study I just spoke about the QC I
automated ACMG classification of over
6000 baraka one and two variants was
99.6% concordant with enigma expert
panel variant assessments with respect
to clinical actionability and as I
mentioned the sources of discordant ear
were really do two nuances in the enigma
scoring framework
so I know we focused a lot of our
attention on bracha testing today but we
also have a complete solution as on a
convention previously for a variety of
diagnostic applications as you can see
here taking you all the way from sample
to insight so thank you so much for your
time thank you dr. euchre and dr.
Poitras for informative presentations I
would also like to thank kyochon for
making today's educational webcast
possible as a final reminder our
speakers will follow up with any
questions you've submitted via email
that's all for now thank you for joining
us we'll see you next time goodbye